I know you're about to tell me that this
was a superb set of local election
results but I'm here with a bit of a
reality check your vote share didn't
grow on the 2019 results when you
extrapolate out to a general election
you're not winning an outright majority
you're well behind where Tony Blair was
in 1995 before his Landslide Victory so
progress up the mountain
that you said you had to climb but
nowhere near enough you must be a bit
disappointed by that this was a very
good set of election results for us and
it puts us on course for a labor
majority and it's not just the numbers
it's where we won you know winning in
places like Medway we haven't won in
Medway since 1998 Dover we haven't won
since 1995. these were key places we
took in the general election of 1997.
Swindon Plymouth Stoke so these are key
Battlegrounds for the general election
so it's it's the fact that we won and
it's where we won but but kiss stormy we
can trade seats and areas so Stockton
you went backwards Walsall Dudley black
country you stood still whole lib Dems
took seats from you okay so we can we
can do that but the big picture here is
that you're giving me a narrative about
an outright majority that no one else is
literally no sofologist has looked at
these results and said that you are on
course for a majority based on these
results confident we're on course we've
looked carefully at these results but I
also under my expert just disagreed with
them to say that spin isn't it
underlying this is the question of why
this has happened and it has happened
because we changed the labor party
people are looking again at the labor
party and also we had an absolute focus
on the cost of living and wherever you
go in the country including all those
places where we one vote it's because
people had trust and confidence in us
and what we were saying about the cost
of living yeah I'm not saying that there
hasn't been progress what I'm putting to
you is every pathologist every expert
everyone that studies these numbers and
they've done them for decades say that
labor is based on these results not on
course for an outright majority and you
keep saying that you are I think we are
I think if you look at where the rabbits
doesn't back it up to read what's
happening in Scotland but look if you're
putting to me that we need to kick on I
completely accept that I'm confident but
I'm not complacent and I know know and
I'm going to be telling the shutter
cabinet in absolutely at no uncertain
terms that the hard bit the hardest bit
is still ahead of us so we're going to
kill you on from these but this is a
very good set of election results for us
and a very very important set of
election results for the conservative so
since you want to level with the public
and be truthful wouldn't be better to
say
we have it in our graphs that we could
win them outright majority but based on
these results we're going to be the
largest party that's actually accurate
isn't it the way you say leveling with
the leveling with the public but what
what actually caused these results was
our laser-like focus on the cost of
living and our ability to show the labor
party had changed we build on that we
kick on from that but I am absolutely
certain that we can kick on now to a
labor majority and and and deliver the
check I mean if anything these elections
told us that people are crying out for
change and I want change for the country
which is why we'll kick onto that
general election you need a swing of
over 10 points you need 124 seat gains
on the national equivalent vote blails
on 47 points against the Tories on 25
back in 1995. you're on 36 points
against the Tories on 2019. the numbers
suck here don't back up what you're
telling me they just don't back it up
you've put a version of this question to
me many times in the last three years my
task was to take the labor party from a
terrible result in 2019 hour since 1935
into a labor majority government and
every year you put that challenge to me
and every year we improve our position
and we make progress we will kick on and
if you said to me I'm more important
that we will get if you said to me I'm
on course to be the next prime minister
but I don't know if that's a minority or
majority government we wouldn't be
having this debate I would be back to us
even if I was the Prime Minister you'd
still be putting to me if that wasn't
well quite well I wouldn't all I'm doing
is put into you what the sofologists say
uh no one agrees with you that you are
on course for an outright majority
literally no one and it's your spin when
I took over as leader labor party people
shook me by the hand I said good luck
and then they said you'll never do it in
one term and now we're being challenged
because we're not further ahead that
shows the progress that we've made but
it's why we've done it it's the
connection with the public about the
issue that matters them all right cost
of living crisis where you say you need
to kick on um the real winner though
that gave you a bit of a kick in as well
as the toys was that Davey is there a
tinch of Envy or fear there from you we
made we the labor party made really
positive games across the country and we
didn't just you know get across the line
in places like Medway this time last
week there was an 11-seat Tory majority
now there's an 11-seat labor majority
and it's that point of connection it's
because we were talking about the things
that matter to people most which is
making ends meet the cost of living
Christ and so can you sat next to where
Davey at the coronation on Saturday is
it a man you can do business with well
look I'm going for an outright majority
and I'm often asked you know will you do
a deal with the SMP and I've been
absolutely clear there are no terms in
which we would do a deal with the SM
yeah I want to push on to a labor
majority what about the lib dams well
look I'm not answering hypotheticals but
you know we what we are aiming for a
labor majority and that's what we're
confident about because you know the try
this
set of local elections was a try for
Change and labor is the party that can
deliver that change okay so you are
ruling out a deal with the s p on any
terms but you're not ruling out a deal
with the lib Dems well as you know with
the SMP it's a fundamental difference I
do not believe no but that's in the
breakup and separation of the United
Kingdom I do not believe that our future
will be better if we put a border
between Scotland and England so it's a
fun there's no basis just to be clear
you're ruling out any sort of
arrangement with the s p and you are not
doing that with the liberal Democrats
I'm clear I'm pressing on I want a labor
majority government workable majority
because the reason I ask sucker is that
last year you said you would not go into
Coalition with anyone including the
little domes you said that at an
interview with Bloomberg so you slightly
changing position no I've said
throughout actually from the day I took
over as leader that I want to go for a
labor majority government
that's my total focus you know the
hypotheticals about what might happen
that goes on for every general election
but what I'm hearing is that you are now
slightly equivocating on the liberal
Democrats because last year you said you
wouldn't have any formal arrangement
with the liberal Democrats and you would
rule out any Arrangement confidence and
Supply formal informal and you're not
just to be really clear it's very
important you're not saying that today
look I I want a clear majority labor
government and one of the reasons we've
made progress in the last three years is
because for all the noises off we've
kept a laser-like focus on the progress
we needed to make as a party we've made
really good progress in these local
elections and now we will kick on and
kick on from majority labor government
so we can bring about the change you
haven't answered my question I'm going
to ask you one more time are you
prepared to come to some sort of
arrangement if necessary informal or
formal with the liberal Democrats but if
you can ask them as many times as you
like the answer is I'm pressing on for a
labor majority at the general level
okay and people will hear that you've
ruled out one and not the other I've got
one more question for you on the Prime
Minister you say he's out of touch is
that personally or politically well I
think it's a combination of both and if
you just on this cost of living if you
compare I swear I can put it I suppose
compare the Prime Minister and me when I
was growing up we couldn't pay our bills
and our phone was cut off and I know the
anxiety I'm actually the shame that that
um it has for families so I know what
people are going through now the problem
I'm not you know he's a wealthy man
that's good I don't knock that but it
means that he doesn't understand I don't
think he doesn't know the anxiety that
people are going through he makes
choices for his own family
understandably I'm not criticizing those
but does he understand the choices that
families across the country are having
to make because of the failure of this
government I don't think he does do you
think that because he sends his children
to private schools and he's used Private
health care in the past that he doesn't
understand
what people are
up against when they're sending their
kids to State schools or when they're
trying to use the NHS yeah I'm not going
to criticize them for where he sent his
children to would you send your kids to
private school no I wouldn't our kids
are in state school would you use
private Health Care no I wouldn't but
I'm not getting into a personal attack
on the Prime Minister for sending his
children to a private school what I am
saying is that sometimes in a cost
living crisis I think is one of them you
have to be able to stand in the shoes of
the voters and properly understand what
they're going through and I don't think
that the prime minister is able to
properly understand the decisions that
families are having to make as a result
of the terrible decisions of his
government just finally you did talk in
pimki's you said the Prime Minister
either is not using the same Public
Services as the rest of us or he's
simply not seeing the damage that to me
is a oblique criticism of the fact that
he doesn't use those Public Service well
the criticism is I I don't think that he
understands what families are going
through I don't think he's got that
point of connection I've got I know what
it feels like to sit around the kitchen
table knowing you can't make ends meet
and that that's an anxiety that is very
real for me so that when we're saying
what we would do in relation costs
living Christ it comes it's a question
of who have you got in your mind when
you make decisions and that's what I
mean by a point of connection final
question uh one to ten
How likely is it going to be that you
will have a majority labor government
next year if there's an election towards
the top end that's what we're going for
eight out of ten well look I'm not gonna
I'm not a betting person I'm not going
to put money on this I'm going to do
what I've done for three and a bit years
now which is I know what I've got to
achieve and I know why I've got to
achieve it and I'm going to shut out the
noise concentrate on and year after year
we make progress we improve and there's
a reason for that we're a changed party
laser focused on the cost of living
which is the single most important thing
for voters okay so okay thank you so
much thank you thank you thank you